revers pour l'opposition le conseil
constitutionnel a rejeté ces deux
recours l'espionnite gagne en allemagne
fédérale à des chefs du
contre-espionnage cette fois pas ça
l'est
après avoir expulsé les travailleurs
tunisiens la libye menacent la tunisie
d'une intervention armée
nouvel épisode de la bataille pour la
publicité comparative à orléans
carrefour épingle ses concurrents sur
leurs prix mesdames messieurs bonsoir
nous l'avons appris il y a tout juste
une heure le pilote du lm ouest allemand
yoakim krenz s'est tué en fin
d'après-midi à millau dans l'aveyron
dans une épreuve du championnat du monde
il était d'ailleurs en tête de ce
championnat fr3 montpellier vient à
l'instant de nous envoyer son reportage
sur cet accident dominique champeau
l'allemand yoakim french était en tête
du championnat mondial du lm et pour une
raison encore indéterminée son appareil
un prototype conspué par les élèves
d'une école aéronautique a décroché
alors qu'il effectue un virage à cent
cinquante mètres d'altitude environ
d'ordinaire les ulm sont munis de
parachute celui de joackim craintes
aujourd'hui faisaient exception à la
règle avec l'accord de la fédération
internationale et ça aussi c'est ultra
léger
le cassis avec elle après un mois de
polémiques le conseil constitutionnel
vient de donner tort à l'opposition sur
les deux recours qu'elle avait déposé à
propos de la loi sur la nouvelle
calédonie une décision dont le premier
ministre laurent fabius s'est réjoui dès
ce soir sa décision
un désaveu catégorie aux personnalités
qui tout récemment avec le pouvoir
attaquer de façon parfois violentes
cette loi et la procédure suivie par les
pouvoirs publics des élections en
nouvelle calédonie vont maintenant
pouvoir avoir lieu au nom même de
l'intérêt général
je souhaite que chacun travaille
désormais à ce qui doit être l'objectif
de tous lors le dialogue la paix et le
développement du territoire
les saisine du conseil constitutionnel
par l'opposition portaient sur deux
points 1
le nombre de conseillers régionaux en
nouvelle calédonie et deux le recours du
chef de l'état à l'article 10 pour
convoquer le parlement en session
extraordinaire
fernand tavarès
tous les membres du conseil
constitutionnel était présent neuf
conseillers élus pour neuf ans six
d'entre eux ont été nommés avant 1981
par valéry giscard d'estaing edgar faure
et alain poher trois autres après 80 par
françois mitterrand et louis mermaz il
ya quinze jours la décision prise par la
haute juridiction de déclarer non
conformes l'article de loi relatifs à la
représentation électorale en
nouvelle-calédonie avait été vivement
critiquée au sein de la majorité
gouvernementale
ceci explique qu'en début de séance un
conseiller glissait dans l'oreille de
son voisin il faut orienter le débat
vers une dépolitisation de la faire
c'est donc dans cet état d'esprit que
les neuf sages ont statué dans
l'explication des décisions rendues le
conseil déclare que l'objet de son
contrôle et non de gêner ou de retarder
l'exercice du pouvoir législatif mais
d'assurer sa conformité à la
constitution dont six concernent le
nombre de représentants de la région de
nouméa
le conseil indique représentation
démographique ne veut pas dire
nécessairement représentation
proportionnelle à la population
d'autres impératif d'intérêt général
peut être prise en compte dans une
mesure limitée a précisé le conseil
constitutionnel donc le choix du
gouvernement
21 conseillers au lieu de 18 a été
approuvé quant à la procédure utilisée
par le chef de l'état pour convoquer le
parlement
elle a été déclarée conforme à la
constitution les juges considèrent que
l'exercice de la prérogatives conférées
au président la république par l'article
10 n'est soumise à aucune autre
condition est que celles prévues à
l'article 19 c'est à dire le contrat du
premier min fed en l'occurrence café
franco mitterrand à qui le conseil
implicitement a donné raison
nous n'avons pu joindre aucun dirigeant
de l'opposition le président du sénat
alain poher un des premiers signataires
des recours avec valéry giscard
d'estaing seulement fait savoir qu'il ne
regrettait pas qu'il leur ferait si
c'était à refaire
le seul qui ait répondu directement nos
questions et le sénateur rpr charles
pasqua
nous l'écoutons le conseil
constitutionnel est une instance florane
il lui appartient de dire le droit en
matière de constitution de l'interpréter
ceux qui ont signé leur cours le
président du sénat l'ancien président de
la république l'ancien premier ministre
nous mêmes avions le sentiment que la
procédure d'une part et certaines
dispositions du texte n'était pas
conforme à la constitution
le conseil constitutionnel a tranché
maintenant nous en prenons acte j'ai
entendu tout à l'heure la déclaration de
monsieur fabrice au cours de laquelle il
déclarait que après on fait un peu
triomphalisme que le dialogue s'engage
que l'ordre
ce soit respecté mais simplement dire ça
fait partie du gouvernement grâce au
sénat chaque bureau de vente à va être
présidé par un magistrat
c'est une garantie mais encore faut-il
que les électeurs la décision du conseil
constitutionnel fait un tabac ce mérite
quelques éclaircissements parce qu'elle
va faire jurisprudence alors on a cru
comprendre que l'opposition déposé le
recours en pensant à l'éventuelle
cohabitation d'après mars 86 et ja oui
alors justement après les délibérations
du conseil constitutionnel on se rend
mieux compte aujourd'hui que le débat
sur ce fameux article 10 est un faux
débat
la constitution de 58 énumère tous les
actes que peut signer seul le président
de la république
ils sont définis à l'intérieur de huit
articles
l'article 10 n'y figurent pas les juges
rappellent ce soir que pour être
applicable la seule initiative du chef
de l'état n'est pas suffisant il faut
qu'elle soit en effet approuvé par la
signature du premier ministre alors
après mars 1986 six lits à changement de
majorité le premier ministre on sait
sera choisi dans l'opposition actuelle
si le nouveau chef du gouvernement est
en désaccord avec une sommité rang sur
l'utilisation cet article 10
eh bien il lui suffira de refuser de
signer on voit donc que ce problème on
est plus en plus fort alors l'autre
recours maintenant celui ci concerne le
mode de représentation électorale
précision capital pour l'avenir des
élections en france le gouvernement et
les parlementaires socialistes avaient
fait remarquer ces derniers jours à
l'opposition que s'il conseille adopté
une définition rigide du critère de
représentation démocratique et n'en
finirait plus d'être saisi alors on sait
très bien que des députés conseillers
généraux et sénateurs sont élus donnent
un exemple global dentelle régions
dépeuplées avec vingt mille voix alors
que dans les grandes agglomérations il
leur en faut 100 milles les sages ont
bien senti qu'il fallait sérieusement
élever le débat et surtout ne pas mettre
la france dans une situation de blocage
pour les échéances électorales
d'aujourd'hui et de demain
alors il faut aussi bien sûr tirer
quelques conclusions politiques
incontestablement raymond barre en
refusant de signer les recours à mieux
calculer son coup valéry giscard
d'estaing
l'objectif de l'opposition était clair
pour d'année une nouvelle fois le
gouvernement est discrédité le président
l'arrêt
public sur ces deux points politiquement
c'est un échec pour les mares
parlementaire udf et rpr qui ont signé
les saisines c'est un échec personnel
aussi pour valéry giscard d'estaing et
le président du sénat qui ont conduit
cette bataille en juriste averti raymond
barre s'est tenue à l'écart et ce soir
évidemment il ne doit pas le regretter
cela dit en dehors de cet enseignement
politique
les nouveaux attendus du conseil
constitutionnel ne manque pas d'intérêt
et ne manqueront pas d'intérêt car ils
rendent beaucoup plus claire la lecture
et l'interprétation de dispositions
fondamentales de notre constitution
après les secrétaires d'infidèles cette
fois c'est un des chefs du
contre-espionnage ouest allemand qui
vient de filer à l'est le gouvernement
fédéral a beau avoir l'habitude cette
fois ils encaissent le coup parce que le
fuyard est tout de même un gros poisson
reichardt ripaud c'est dans cette maison
que vivait au hac limited que les
voisins le décrivent comme un homme
dépressif alcoolique est endetté le type
même de l'homme sur lequel on peut faire
pression et que les services de
renseignement recherche
seulement voilà yoakim tieger était
placée très haut dans la hiérarchie du
contre-espionnage ouest allemand et il
avait accès à presque tous les secrets
de son service
son départ survient après trois autres
défections dont celle de sonia lunebourg
la propre secrétaire du ministre de
l'économie à tel point qu'aujourd'hui à
bonn règne une certaine psychose à la
mata hari parmi les hommes politiques
mais les secrétaires et les
fonctionnaires ne sont pas les seuls
agents à l'oeuvre en allemagne la ferme
and fred roches qui a éclaté il ya
quelques mois est là pour le prouver
cet ingénieur de chez messerschmitt
travaillait depuis 30 ans pour le kgb et
avait livré à ses employeurs plusieurs
secrets concernant l'aéronautique
bref la république fédérale d'allemagne
ressemble plutôt à une fourmilière pour
espions de l'est et surtout de
l'allemagne de l'est
il ya question de langue question
d'adaptation de présence et un roman de
facilité qui n'existe pas entre les deux
pays voisins en occident comme dans les
pays de l'est
c'est la même nation et tout se passe à
l'intérieur de la même nation qui encore
une fois appartient à deux alliances
est-ce que les affaires d'espionnage ont
lieu également avec d'autres pays que
l'allemagne de l'est beaucoup moins
d'après les statistiques publiées
à bonn 80 à 90% des affaires depuis
l'existence de république fédérale d
puis d'innocents 42 49 concerne la rda
c'est pas par hasard à bonn le passage à
l'est de new york tim filc a été
qualifié de sérieux et lourds de
conséquences
le secrétaire d'état à l'intérieur en
tenaille celle annoncé la création d'une
commission d'enquêté chargée de limiter
les dégâts ce sont ses propres termes
quant au chancelier kohl désir soir il
était sorti de sa réserve pour estimer
que ces affaires d'espionnage pouvait
peser sur les relations interallemande
propos fermes mais relativement mesurés
campagne d'intimidation guerre
psychologique menace mais en même temps
de part et d'autre on souhaite ménager
l'avenir et je crois que berlin est et
bones ont beaucoup d'intérêts en commun
qui sont beaucoup plus importants que
les divergences idéologiques a dit
valence tout court
l'allemagne s'est habitué à vivre avec
ces espions aucun régime n'y échappe
il y à 11 ans la sphère gunther
guillaume avait coûté son poste au
chancelier social-démocrate vibrante à
tout le moins la sphère dit que obligera
les allemands de l'ouest à réorganiser
tous leurs services de contre espionnage
ça va très mal entre la tunisie et la
libye à l'expulsion des travailleurs
tunisiens à la libye vient d'ajouter
pour la première fois des menaces très
clair d'intervention armée
la tunisie qui en appelle à ses amis et
à l'onu a rappelé son ambassadeur et
proteste officiellement contre les
menaces libyenne mémona cg hintermann
c'est tunisien avait trouvé du travail
en libye où ils étaient près de cent
mille partir ou choisir la nationalité
libyenne c'était le marché de dupes de
tripoli ils ont refusé la nouvelle
nationalité
les volets donc jetés sur les routes de
l'exode ils ont subi de mauvais
traitements les libyens ont gardé leur
passeport et leur économie plus de 23000
d'entre eux ont déjà été expulsés le
chômage les attend réaction rapide de
tunis après les plus hauts de deux cent
cinquante trois libyens accusés
d'espionnage mardi 30 diplomates libyens
ont été sommés de quitter la tunisie
sous la même accusation
l'egypte dont cent mille ressortissants
ont également été expulsés de libye n'a
pas riposté
seuls les travailleurs marocains et
soudanais sont épargnés pour le moment
le colonel kadhafi qui doit tenir cours
des difficultés économiques réelles de
son pays
reproche surtout à la tunisie ces refus
d'une grande confédération arabe et le
voyage du président bourguiba aux états
unis en juin a ajouté à sa colère on est
loin aujourd'hui des embrassades de 1983
à monastir la tunisie craint que parmi
le flot d'expulser certains tunisiens
endoctrinés entraînée en libye
les pour mission de déstabiliser le pays
l'armée tunisienne est en alerte
la libye est prête à faire usage de la
force a dit hier responsables libyens
aux chargés d'accueil tunisie à tripoli
la france a exprimé son soutien à la
tunisie mais la tunisie souhaitait un
engagement plus précis paris ne souhaite
pas je cite un responsable français
jeter de l'huile sur le feu car nous
avons eu un contentieux déjà assez lourd
avec la libye paris pense d'ailleurs que
la tunisie a réagi trop vivement
tunis est conseillé de ne pas envenimer
la situation avec son voisin en afrique
du sud on attend la journée de mercredi
prochain avec inquiétude ce jour là en
effet une grande marche est organisée au
cap pour demander à nouveau
la libération de nelson mandela le chef
du congrès national africain condamné à
la prison à vie il ya 14 ans l'appel
lancé par le révérend bouzac président
des églises réformées s'accompagne d'une
demande au gouvernement sud africain ne
provoquait pas notre peuple par une
présence militaire il on peut se
demander s'il sera entendu la nuit
dernière si noir ont été tués par la
police
et aujourd'hui encore des centaines de
jeunes ont été arrêtés gérard pinson en
cinq semaines d'état d'urgence dans les
cités noires 2200 personnes ont été
arrêtées la moitié d'entre elles restent
détenus aujourd'hui à soweto les normes
banlieue de johannesburg
plus de 300 jeunes ont été arrêtés
certains âgés d'à peine 13 ans pour le
chef de la police ils font partie des
5000 jeunes criminels manipulés par le
parti communiste et qui sème le désordre
des jeunes qui seraient à l'origine des
incendies de la nuit dernière à al youm
au nord du cap émeutes au cours
desquelles la police a ouvert le feu à
deux reprises tuant six noir et en
blessant 24 à soweto autour d'un
commissariat
monseigneur toutou s'est retrouvé
aujourd'hui au milieu d'une foule de
parents qui tentait d'obtenir la remise
en liberté de leurs enfants situation
inconfortable pour le prix nobel de la
paix qui lui aussi bien sûr s'associer à
la grande marche de mercredi prochain au
cap pour la libération de mandela en
priant dieu qu'elle n'entraîne pas de
nouveaux morts en afrique du sud
nouvel épisode de la bataille pour la
publicité comparative le 13 juin dernier
le gouvernement disait toujours non le
ministre des finances pierre bérégovoy
compte bien revenir à la charge et
obtenir même un débat au parlement à
l'automne
en attendant des tentatives ont lieu
carrefour par exemple qui compare ses
prix à ceux de ses concurrents une
action à dire vrai ni légale ni légale
car elle n'est ni autorisé ni interdite
bref c'est ce qu'on appelle un vide
juridique il était tentant de s'y
glisser c'est ce qu'a fait carrefour à
orléans
dominique duforest il faut le dire nous
sommes les moins chers et afin de le
faire savoir le magasin carrefour de sa
ronde dont la banlieue d'orléans a
comparé les prix de 47 de ses articles
avec ceux affichés par ses concurrents
régionaux
auchan et leclerc bilan apparent et
publié sur une pleine page hier dans le
quotidien la république du centre
carrefour est le moins cher à ce jour
interdit cette publicité comparative
mais rien ne la règlement de comptes ont
donc baissé ses prix avant d'en faire
établir le relevé par un juif il est
vrai qu'en début d'année suite à cette
enquête que j'évoquais les prix et au
niveau de notre magasin ont été baissés
et c'est seulement dernièrement que il
nous a paru intéressant de les comparer
par rapport à nos concurrents pour
stimulant par la concurrence
et vous croyez que c'est vraiment moins
cher ici qu'ailleurs pour l'instant yeah
yeah man certainement pas pour l'instant
dernièrement c'est à dire d'avant les
vacances j'ai trouvé que c'était un
petit peu plus cher et nous réagissez ce
matin dans la république du centre le
magasin leclerc d'olive et que carrefour
avait oublié de citer dans sa publicité
hier justement cette grande surface du
sud d'orléans inaugurait de nouveaux
locaux et son propriétaire aurait aimé
être comparé est ce que vous allez me
lancer dans le field operations vous
avez déjà loué une page de journal
oui parce que je pense qu'il l'est pour
faire passer le message rapidement que
ces gens en friche qui trichent pourquoi
parce que sur les orgues
carrefour est connu comme un magasin à
chair dans cette affaire carrefour est
dans l'illégalité la plus totale car il
y a
concurrence déloyale et il y a citation
de noms de marque et d'un feignent sans
autorisation du propriétaire de la
marque ou du propriétaire
en revanche les services de contrôle de
l'administration dans la mesure où la
publicité comparative n'est pas
interdite ne peuvent rien faire la
publicité comparative
comme vous le dites n'est pas interdite
elle est rendue impossible
et par contre les services pourrait
intervenir sur la base de la publicité
mensongère ou induisant le consommateur
en erreur
s'il s'avérait qu'en plus les prix ne
soit pas effective dans les magasins
cité pour remédier au manque
d'objectivité le pdg de leclerc à olivet
propose que tous les hypers d'orléans
achète en commun une page et l'offre
quand un organisme de consommateurs qui
lui mènera l'enquète les consommateurs
ont maintenant l'habitude dé publicité
cachée sous le voile du désintéressement
les publicités ont eu l'habitude de
jouer avec les journalistes
nous essayons nous y faire
un record du monde d'athlétisme celui du
marocain said aouita sur 1500 m en 3
minutes 29 secondes et 45 centièmes
l'ancien record 22 centièmes de plus
appartenait au britannique steve cram et
ça va vite c'était le 16 juillet dernier
à nice football un match avancé de la 8e
journée du championnat de france ce soir
nancy a battu nice 3 à 0
voile les quatorze rescapés de la course
de l'europe ont repris la mer ce matin à
lorient cap sur lisbonne distance 650000
pour cette 5e étape
ils on peut se demander si ces bateaux
géants ne sont pas des colosses aux
pieds d'argiles à en juger par la casse
qui a eu encore aujourd'hui l'oeil
thévenard 14h10 aujourd'hui coups de
canon à lorient ils sont repartis sous
le crachin breton pour aller faire le
soleil du portugal on espère pour eux en
tout cas cette 5e étape de la course de
l'europe elle est importante car les
longues relativement 650000 c'est
l'occasion pour les candidats à la
victoire de faire le trou entre eux et
le reste du peloton
c'est un petit lada poch skippé par
loïck peyron qui a coupé la ligne en
tête
mais le pauvre avait été devancé par les
maxi les grands bateaux
charente-maritime un royal ou crédit
agricole
par contre un autre favori jet services
n'a pas eu cette chance
le haut de sa grand voile à nouveau
lâché le vent était pourtant très faible
coup dur pour patrick morvan obligé de
revenir au port civic incident bizarre
également les voiles du catamaran novell
network ont été lacérées cette nuit par
des inconnus mais c'est réparé la course
continue le premier lisbonne prendra une
option sur la victoire mais il restera
deux manches encore aux autres pour le
rattraper décidément la course de
l'europe est une bonne formule car c'est
demain à vincennes dans le prix ovide us
les pronostics de monsieur courtine sur
les dix-huit partants il a choisi les
numéros 16 qui est son joker 18 11 13 17
6 et 9
le temps demain la journée commencera
bien avec du soleil une fois quelques
bancs de brouillard dissiper mais cela
se gâtera très vite car des nuages et de
la pluie aborderont la bretagne dès le
matin
et envahiront tout le pays au cours de
la journée une fois passée cette
perturbation on reverra quelques
éclaircies naturellement les
températures s'en ressentiront elle vous
voyez iront de 17 degrés près de la
manche et en bretagne à 30 degrés dans
le sud
demain soir nous avons rendez-vous à
21h35 après ce journal rencontre de
l'été prélude à la nuit avant de nous
quitter
le rappel des titres de l'actualité
bonsoir à demain revers pour
l'opposition le conseil constitutionnel
a rejeté ces deux recours l'espionnite
gagne en allemagne fédérale un des chefs
du contre-espionnage cette fois pas ça
l'est
après avoir expulsé les travailleurs
tunisiens la libye menacent la tunisie
une intervention armée
voile les quatorze rescapés de la course
de l'europe en vo thi pour lisbonne
il